division agents caleb dunn
and heather ward have been tracking a
woman known as mantis all the way from
new york to maryland
enlisting the help of agent brian
johnson they are finally able to bring
the fight to a front door
however they soon find themselves at the
heart of something much larger than what
they had expected
and this event triggers something that
leads him directly to washington dc
[Music]
like a number of kids growing up in
santa cruz brian johnson began surfing
at a very early age
and because of his natural talents was
well set on his way to going pro
however the consequence of a bad breakup
had him making a rash decision
and he decided to enlist in the navy
there he discovered something that drove
him to want to push himself even further
than he would have ever imagined
and so he joined the police department
in baltimore and later became a sniper
within their quick response team
along the way he was recruited by the
strategic homeland division
and during the early days of the
outbreak he spent a lot of his time
trying to combat the growing crisis
around him
all while witnessing a number of his
friends succumbed to the disease
during this time brian saw many things
that deeply and emotionally scarred him
and had a very hard time processing that
trauma and still is
the early days of the outbreak were the
hardest days for brian all of his
friends
especially within the baltimore police
department had died
so he had made his way alone to fort
meade where he would help defend the
government facility
all the while trying to forget the
terrible things he had witnessed
baltimore had become a war zone decades
of built up rage and frustration
finally exploded and was only further
fueled by the green poison
dun and heather approach compound
outside the barricade they see an agent
overseeing the perimeter
his name is brian johnson introducing
themselves they explain to him that they
have something in their possession that
needs decrypting
they have fought many battles on the
road to this location and although it's
nice to finally see another friendly
face
they don't know enough about this person
to share just yet the exact reasons why
they're here
brian understands that this is a need to
know situation and therefore proceeds to
take them to the compound and directly
to the person in charge of the facility
once in front of the deputy director dun
and heather disclose everything they
have witnessed
they revealed their information on
mantis and what they had found at her
office at the water treatment facility
they also informed the deputy director
of the two hostile groups mantis has
been supplying weapons and technology to
and expressed their brief that it is for
the sole purpose of distraction
and keeping the division busy the deputy
director wasn't overly convinced by the
story
as over the months they've been dealing
with a large influx of conspiracy
theories
and to her this sounded just as crazy as
some of the others
however after having a look at the radio
hardware they had acquired
she agreed to have one of their teams
work on it
the tech personnel said it would be at
least a week before they were able to
get any answers
they make a start on it but for now dun
and heather are being forced to have a
bit of a break
brian has been defending this vital
government installation for the last few
months
and although no one would dare question
his devotion there has been very little
in the way of hostile activity around
these paths
along with the boredom brian has had
plenty of time to reflect
this time has been good for him to get
to grips with what he saw in the early
days following the outbreak
and with the introduction of these two
agents from new york and philadelphia
he has been brought back to reality with
what is currently happening out there in
the world
he notices how these two agents are
quite an odd duo
dunn seems to be struggling with some
memories of his past where heather
appears far more optimistic
and positive around the current
situation yet they have come together to
put a stop to a grave threat that is far
bigger than their own problems
brian has been consumed by what he
witnessed after the release of the green
poison
but he is now ready to face who he is
and get going on the job that he swore
to do
as a division agent by now he was fully
briefed on mantis
and understands the full scale of this
new threat when the techies have
finished their job
he'll be joining dunn and heather on
their journey
eventually the hardware team crack the
device and provide them with the means
to track the signal
it leads them west towards frederick
what would have been an hour's drive
before the outbreak is now a number of
days walk
and although urgency is a concern the
road is dangerous and caution is
required
they track the signal to a farm running
some recon on the property beforehand
they immediately notice the fresh tire
tracks outside
petrol is incredibly difficult to come
by these days this only further supports
their suspicion of it being a part of
something much bigger
crouched out of sight they survey the
farmhouse
brian suggests that they get some
support from the jtf close by
at fort detrick though as he suspected
brian isn't willing to wait
at risk of losing mantas again so they
make a plan to advance on the house
to get in range of isaac scanners to see
if any hostiles are picked up
brian and dunn move towards the house
while hear the flanks around the side
towards the barn
in the farmhouse the security system
picks up on the unknown movement from
outside
soldiers dressed in black suddenly
appear from the house and open fire on
dunn and brian
isaac still hasn't picked them up they
must be using something to block its
scanners
meanwhile heather is made away into the
barn parked in the middle is a
military-grade humvee
over the gunfight happening outside
heather hears the creek of a door
followed quickly by a shower of bullets
she manages to duck into cover
and radios through to dun and brian
signaling that she has a visual on
mantis
mantis jumps into the humvee and speeds
out of the barn in brian and dun's
direction
but before she is able to make it very
far heather rushes out from the barn
using a grenade launcher she manages to
attach a remote detonation device
onto the back of the vehicle the humvee
is blown forward and on top of its roof
with flames billowing out from the
underside the three agents cautiously
approach the wreckage
suddenly the side door pops open firing
a burst of rounds
she runs while the agents hit the ground
brian returns fire
and dunn takes off after her injured
from the crash
it doesn't take long for dunn to catch
up to mantis
he tackles her to the ground and after a
short fight he finds himself in a
situation where he could enter once and
for all
all the built up rage and vengeance has
led him to this point
where he could simply kill her where
they stand and avenge the loss of his
friend that she brutally murdered in
front of him
but with heather pleading for him not to
do it he finally came to the realization
that this wasn't him
this wasn't what he signed up to do and
that killing her won't fix the grief
that he is feeling
throwing it to the ground dunn takes a
few steps back while heather cuffs her
but it isn't over suddenly all agents
notice their watches have gone dead
and that the connection to the shd
network has been cut off
lifting mantis to her feet it's obvious
that her people were responsible for
this
but before they could start questioning
her there was a huge explosion
they could see the smoke in the distance
rising above the tree line
it was fort detrick making their way
towards the location
they can see the shared devastation that
has been unleashed
fort detrick is a part of the biological
defense program the army medical command
was stationed here
this organization had even greater
resources than they had originally
thought
and that they had timed this attack
perfectly with the crash of the division
network
how far widespread were these attacks
what was left in new york
philadelphia washington dc
this was an attack on the united states
but with their communications down
they had no idea where they were needed
but before they could discuss this
further
they heard the sudden crack of a bullet
hitting its target
mantis had been shot before she'd even
hit the ground
the three agents had found cover the
shot had come from a marksman rifle
around 800 yards away but it was obvious
that this was meant for mantis
likely in an attempt to silence her
before they were able to extract any
information
dunn heather and brian discuss what to
do next
with the shd network down they're
sitting ducks
but they have no idea what the cause of
it was and where to go
all they currently have to work with is
some coordinates that their watches are
showing
this would be their first stop for
answers
the three agents spend the next two
weeks traveling on foot
the coordinates led them to the nation's
capital washington dc
the backup protocol for when isaac goes
down is for all agents to be called to
dc
so they have no idea what they're about
to walk into
all they know is that they're the
division the country's last line of
defense
the last stand
and that concludes the extrema smeller
series
i absolutely love how this lines up with
the beginning of the division ii
sort of a mini prequel to the story
giving us a bit more background on
mantis and the black tusk before their
full invasion
again and i know i've said this in all
three videos but credit where credit is
due and all that
this has been part three of the division
comic book series that came out at the
beginning of the division
ii you can find these on darkhorse.com
thank you very much for watching i hope
you've enjoyed these and i'll catch you
in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh